- Have y'all met Selena before?
- I have not.
- First time.
- Just now.
- Okay, she might've been
the one stalking you Comic
Con or whatever it's called.
CrimeCon.
- CrimeCon.
- There's all these Cons.
I don't know, I need to go to them.
So y'all were called the
Rolling Stones of true crime.
That's a pretty sexy title, y'all.
I'm just sayin'.
- Yeah.
- We paid the guy.
- You paid for it.
What does it feel like though?
If you're Rolling Stones of true crime
that means everyone watches you.
- It's weird.
- I've been a journalist
for a long time and that
just doesn't happen.
I certainly didn't see this coming.
When we started doing
true crime stories about,
I don't know, a little bit
more than 10 years ago,
I didn't wanna do it.
I wasn't interested.
Usually when you're covering cops--
- Time flies, John.
- It does.
- It must've been closer to 20.
- Well, we've been here--
- Who's counting?
- We've been here 25 years.
You're counting.
- We've been a dateline 25 years each.
- Wow, you must like it.
So, you're a big fan, right?
- Yes.
- Do you have any questions?
- Okay, what's the craziest
story that you can remember?
- Oh gosh, there's been so many.
- The one you're on now.
- Yeah sure, you know the
missing kids in Idaho.
The one's the Hawaii connection,
the Arizona, all of it.
So we're chasing around--
- Wait what?
There's missing kids in Idaho and Hawaii?
What did you say?
I don't know this.
- You don't know this story?
- No, I don't know this.
Tell me this story.
- Oh okay, well,
they disappeared in September,
the authorities have been
trying to get the mother
of those children and her new husband
to reveal where they are,
and if they will just reveal it
all this might go away.
But, there's also the
question of the new husband's
ex-wife who mysteriously passed away,
though she was very healthy.
- What?
- The new wife's ex-husband
whose brother shot her.
But then later on her
brother mysteriously died.
- There's this trail of death
that is following these
people around the country.
- I can't even keep up
with what you just said.
- No, no, no.
- I was literally train A to train B,
there's so many crazy things
in what you just said.
- It's the most complicated
story I've ever--
- He compressed that into about
two hours, a few weeks ago,
and it was pretty hard to do then.
- Yeah, it was.
- Oh my gosh.
Do y'all ever have nightmares
from all the things that you see?
I always wonder from
investigators or cops,
or journalists, people doing this.
That's why I had to kinda
check out for a bit,
because I started freaking out,
thinking everyone was gonna kill me.
I'd lock my doors all the time.
I literally am the friend my assistant
and my nanny, everybody will tell you.
I make everyone text me when they're home,
and they've checked their house.
This is a real thing.
Y'all don't get affected by it?
- First of all, that's not a bad idea.
- Exactly, that's what I said!
- It's not a bad idea, right?
- Josh?
Yes, it's like they wanna be on your show.
- That's not a bad idea.
- That's a terrible idea.
- It is not a terrible idea!
- No, it's an awful idea.
- Buddy system, let
people know you're safe.
- Absolutely.
- But y'all don't get phased by it?
- No, in fact the crime
rate has gone down.
- Well that's good.
There aren't as many murders
as there used to be.
- Are you bummed?
Dang it.
Wish there could be more crime.
- Look, you know, you do see
some terrible things in this job.
You also see some stories
of tremendous strength
and redemption, and people
who struggle against
really terrible things
that have happened to them,
and end up doing things
that they wouldn't have thought possible.
So you see families, which are suffering,
and they manage to come through.
And that's one of the
inspirational things about this,
and the other is this
show's really sort of
about the best in law enforcement.
- It's true
- Yeah.
- I'm telling ya', the
people who solve crimes
in this country, even though sometimes
they get a bad reputation once in awhile,
are overall the most
committed, marvelous people
you could ever hope to meet.
And especially homicide detectives.